newly released video shows a Colorado
man convicted of killing his family
confessing to the murder of his pregnant
wife
Christopher watts is seen in a police
interrogation room telling his father he
killed his wife Shannon in a fit of rage
he pleaded guilty this month and
received a life sentence Jericka Duncan
is here with new information revealed in
video and court documents Jericka good
morning good morning glad last week
Shannon Watson's father called his
former son-in-law an evil monster well
yesterday the Weld County District
Attorney's Office released a trove of
evidence related to the case than the
evidence paints watts as a manipulative
and calculated killer body camera
footage shows police searching
Christopher Watson's home after his
pregnant wife and two young daughters
disappeared Watts told investigators he
was worried but in a video confession
days later Watts told his father he
murdered Shannon in a fit of rage
claiming she killed their children
[Music]
a neighbor security camera captured
watts leaving his driveway apparently
with his family's bodies in his truck
the bodies of four-year-old Celeste and
three-year-old Bella were found days
later in oil tanks where watts worked
Shannan was found in a shallow grave
nearby prosecutors say watts killed his
family because of an affair he was
having with a co-worker Nicole Kessinger
and a recorded interview with police the
day Shannon and the girls were found
dead
Kessinger appeared distraught despite
portraying a happy family on social
media text messages between Shannon and
watts and the weeks leading up to the
murders showed a fractured relationship
according to court documents on August
6th Shannan texted watts
make me feel like everything is going to
be okay watts replied it will be okay
this will all get fixed a week later his
family was dead
according to those court documents that
the day that Watts killed his family he
called his daughter school to say they
would no longer be attending and he also
contacted a real estate agent about
selling his home he will spend the rest
of his life in prison Nora
it's just horrific the details of this
tarika thank you